i
ah
[Música]
yo
una noche le pregunté a mi madre
madre porque en las noches dice y lo q q
el búho
mi madre me dijo extraña su esposa
yo le pregunté cuál es esposa del búho
ella mirando al cielo me dijo es la luna
le pregunté madre tú cómo sabes esto
nosotros sabemos hablar con la
naturaleza mediante los sueños es ahí
donde conocemos como el mundo de la
naturaleza de la selva se comunica el
mundo espiritual invisible y los seres
que ya no están con nosotros
los muertos se comunican con nosotros
los sueños nos ayudan a mejorar nuestra
vida
yo también fui aprendiendo mucho de este
mundo mágico de mi madre mi madre fue de
una familia muy grande más de 20.000
saparas y grandes conocedores de la
medicina tradicional ancestral
pero hoy en la actualidad el pueblo está
para la nación sea para sólo quedamos
575 saparas y tres ancianas hablan
nuestro idioma
nosotros estamos ubicados aquí en el
territorio ecuatoriano al sureste de la
provincia de pastaza
yo también empecé a soñar ya comunicarme
con estos seres espirituales en los
sueños ellos me entregaban muchas lanzas
y me decían que debía que llevar por
todos los lugares que yo fuera y lanzar
pero yo aún no sabía interpretar los
sueños pero nuevamente soñé lanzas pero
en este en esta vez soñé a una mujer muy
grande y a un jaguar estos dos seres me
entregaban lanzas y me decían que
lanzara donde estaban sentado muchos
animales yo lanzaba dos de las lanzas en
la mañana le pregunté a mi tío si manu
un sabio espiritual tío qué significa
este sueño él me dijo hoy día te vas a
dar cuenta de este sueño beso cogió de
la mano y me soplo
y de la corona
en el día vio una reunión super grande
donde yo estoy invitado solo a escuchar
pero no tenía no opinar pero cuando
entró la líder me dijo ya anda tú
también vas a hablar opinar en esta
reunión y me acordé de los sueños de las
lanzas que me entregaban estos seres era
mi palabra mi voz que iba a dar
los animales que soñé era el público
también les conté este sueño
en 1992 fue el primer levantamiento de
los pueblos indígenas del ecuador que
partió desde la provincia de pastaza
desde la comunidad de unión base hacia
la ciudad de quito
en esa época
no existían comunicadores amazónicos no
existía la información desde el
territorio en esta marcha también sexis
se exigía el reconocimiento del estado
plurinacional el reconocimiento de las
de los territorios ancestrales y la
educación bilingüe y otras demandas pero
también habían comunicadores que
comunicaban a su interés no difundían
todo pero en esta última marcha que
también partió desde unión base del 28
de noviembre del 2007
caminamos 15 días desde un envase
también aquí nos dimos cuenta que
después de 26 años nuestra información
no estaba siendo difundida por los
medios tradicionales de comunicación al
mundo entonces nosotros los
comunicadores que estoy un disperso en
el gran territorio y en la gran marcha
debíamos que tomar una iniciativa de
unidad y tomar acciones directas porque
nuestra marcha no estaba siendo conocida
en ese entonces nosotros como
comunicadores nos juntamos para crear
una gran
unidad
en esta marcha surgimos nosotros como
lanceros digitales
debíamos que posesionaron la gran marcha
y difundir a través de los medios de
comunicación que había las redes
sociales la radio la televisión entonces
nuestra información de la marcha se
estaba lanzando al mundo a través de los
lanceros digitales nuestro sueño más
adelante como lanceros digitales es
tener
y crear una gran red de comunicadores de
todo el mundo para cuidar lo último que
nos queda que es la naturaleza también
para ir utilizando la tecnología como
una herramienta de construcción y
resistencia
nosotros
comunicamos al mundo
decimos a través de estos medios el
porqué cuidamos la naturaleza
el porqué
yo sueño
el porqué viajo contando esto
para soñar mi vida mi camino me
enseñaron muchas las plantas por eso por
eso el mundo los pueblos indígenas de
todos del mundo protegen
los territorios la selva las montañas
porque ahí está el conocimiento la vida
del presentes y futuras generaciones
nuestras voces comunican energía de vida
nuestras voces comunican las voces de
los seres espirituales así funciona
muchas personas creen que sus voces no
emiten fuerza ni poder pero nuestro
mundo indígena estamos seguro que cada
cuerpo es un transmisor de comunicación
de energía
tu voz tiene lanza fuerza poder y
energía nosotros los saparas soñamos
para vivir y vivimos para soñar y chajá
[Aplausos]